I remember when I was a young man my
mama took me to the store and I stared
out of my mind as I stared at that
dressing room door I was like what if
the pants are you like
well it's like she knew my berries or
defensive but the name
I met my wife my wife hakusho with
branches my first boob in the first time
I read
I did it all in my t-shirt
well geez are pretty great they're very
cool
then you comes terrible
but so it's hard to argue that they go
and we sure can say a little
- after my YouTube fancy pants or
chickens Jesus knows everybody but if
you really wanna know what I love
this wardrobe is
about what
in there I want to tell you with my
mouth
no at the clothes I wear
well I think
like my line
which is why we're here
I have to talk to that you can find out
who I am John we're going on tour we're
starting in Kansas and going a bunch of
places in Texas and then across Arizona
and up California it's pretty short tour
just 10 days you're touring with wheezy
waiters band Driftless Pony Club and
herring the Potters who have probably
the best live show I've ever seen shows
are fun and laid-back and we do our best
to pack them full of interesting stuff
in green and the perfect strangers go on
last but I sort of emcee the whole
evening it's very fun tickets are on
sale now for all of that it's except El
Paso I'm sorry El Paso we'll figure it
out though and I'll let you know we'll
have some great merch shirts and posters
and a flash drive that contains every
song I've ever written on it and if you
pay in cash we'll do our best to give
you your change including a $2 bill that
I have signed cuz that's weird we have a
great time and all these people on
Twitter agree I got some testimonials
just searched Hank green concert it's
fun
come along John I'll see you on Tuesday